hey everybody how's everybody doing
today that's me that's the stock all
right so I'm going to talk about the
future but first we're gonna talk about
the 90s bait-and-switch I actually used
to live up here in the 90s I grew up up
here and the fashion just hasn't changed
at all it was it's just sweat shirts and
fleece from REI back in the 90s there'd
be like some neon windbreakers but it's
basically the same so back in the 90s
there was actually like this real fight
like kind of a war over what the future
of the internet would look like there
wasn't really an established application
platform
it was globally accessible and the view
of a lot of people including like the
vast majority of the tech industry
actually and Bill Gates was that you
would have this thing that bill liked to
call the information superhighway which
was like you would just connect to
companies products and they would all be
like unique and then you would download
their software and then connect to like
their backends and stuff to think about
it now it sounds relatively dystopic
like you had just connected these
corporate sites and get their content
but like AOL was like the most
successful version of this right which
was it was a content portal and rather
than using the web you would use this
content portal and everybody thought
that this was gonna win not a lot of
people thought in the web was gonna win
and if you're looking at them like yeah
you can kind of see why like this is a
little more useable like there's a
taxonomy I can click on things that I
can do in like what is over here and
they had this amazing thing called like
keywords so like if I was like hey I had
this awesome website so you type like
HTTP colon slash slash and like the
browsers were dumb they would not fill
this in for you and and then uh Oprah
like every day on her show would get up
there and Oprah would be like yes
keyword Oprah look it up on AOL and then
you get all this content from Oprah on
AOL like of course this is gonna win
Oprah is gonna win we're not gonna win
and just like I'm generally better
experience but the thing that ended up
happening is that the web had this thing
called URLs and then people who publish
things
would link to other people's URLs and
that seems like a really simple thing
and it's like this primitive that we
really take for granted but like the if
you wanted to publish something on AOL
your first step was like be Oprah and
then step two was like pay people to put
up content on the web like anybody can
get an earl and you can put up stuff and
then you can link to other people's
stuff and even though girls were much
worse to say than keywords they allow
these kinds of network effects to happen
because you can link to other people's
stuff so like I make my Oprah blog we
didn't have blogs in the 90s but you get
my point
and then like somebody like publishes
their list of favorite Oprah sites and
somebody makes an Oprah web ring and
this all kind of piles on together and
eventually what you end up with is this
big network graph of different people
providing different content and so Oprah
is content on a o L was a lot better
than like any one person's favorite
blogs or anything like that
but when you take the entire value of
this big network and all this activity
that's happening and all this
exponential growth of this network
around all that content it just doesn't
even compare anymore to the content that
you had inside of these portals and so
these network effects are effectively
why the web one and when we we go to
compare the value of AOL at all just
like really high-end well published
content we're comparing it to this the
value of the web which is like this huge
exponentially growing graph of data and
value that's why the web one and I think
that is really easy today to forget
about these primitives and why they were
so important we really need to unwind
our view of the web today when we think
about the web we think about standards
and browsers and web frameworks and
JavaScript and like that is all very
important and like I you know I did no
js' stuff for nine years I think that
like JavaScript is very important I
serve on the node foundation it is a
very important thing but if we're
thinking about what are the current
limitations of the web and what are the
primitives that we need in order to move
forward we really need to come back to
the basics and unwind and think about
URLs and links so this is an earl and
there's basically three distinct parts
a transport and authority and then a
reference to the content you're getting
and you can sort of think about this
backwards right first you name content
that you're going to publish so you
create some kind of name for it or like
an index then there's the who-who D who
do I ask for on the Internet for this
content right and then the transport
says like how I asked this person for
that content and so when I link to
somebody else's site
I'm actually giving them a central
location to go and look this up I'm
saying go to this Authority and ask
somebody for this content right and
that's that's the base primitive that we
built everything for the last 20 years
on centralization is baked into that
primitive right
it's federated in in a general sense but
like the whole web is federated but
every individual actor is actually
centralized so web locations are more
than just static assets in the browser
right static assets in the browser I can
manipulate they're part of the open web
like I can and do change like everything
in Facebook
sorry I don't really go to Facebook but
Twitter like I remove all the ads I
change words that make me stressed out
like Trump to things that don't stress
me out like Daisy's like it's just you
know I have like a series of dumb
extensions to just change everything
about that experience the problem though
is that like Twitter and and modern web
applications in general aren't just
these static assets they pull
information out of api's and those api's
are addressed by those URLs they're like
in these central locations I can't just
replace it the way that I can replace
stuff that's in my browser and so this
means that data centralization is baked
in to multi-user applications on the web
today there just isn't a good way for me
to go and build an application that
multiple users interact with and have
relationships between those peoples data
without just centralizing in an enjoying
content silo and putting an API in front
of it so this is one of the largest cost
drivers of modern applications it makes
them expensive like Brian stockett at
the beginning of the day was brilliant
because you know it really is pennies
now to just run thousands of function
executions in the cloud but if you log
like a little bit of data from all of
those calls
the storage cost of the logs is more
expensive than the processing of the
actual cloud functions storage actually
still does cost money and unlike odd
functions that like Evan flow with like
how active your website is storage only
really increases over time it's why it's
such a good business to be in like we're
here so but but the biggest problem that
we really have with with these data
silos isn't just it like we can't get
our data out of them or that they're
opaque which they are it's that they you
have to basically build an ad model to
support most large websites and that
again comes back to URLs and links if I
want to benefit from the network effects
of the web I have to be able to link you
to my content which means that my
content has to be publicly accessible it
can't be behind a paywall so like any
application that gets popular enough
through these network effects is gonna
have to be ad supported in order to fund
all these costs eventually these a
driven businesses started to get smarter
and smarter they started to adopt a lot
of really good machine learning and new
algorithms and eventually what they
figured out is that the best way to
capture your attention for the longest
amount of time is to keep moving you
towards more and more extreme content
and so you're effectively radicalizing
people like on purpose because it's a
very good way to keep you watching
YouTube like forever and our current
like we don't we just have no recourse
right like the people in this room are
developers like we we're going to build
the next version of one of these
applications and we have no other tool
than to build it the same way that we've
always built it and end up with all of
the exact same problems again our only
other resource is literally to yell at
billionaires and try to ask them to
change their algorithms to make less
money like they didn't become
billionaires by making less money off of
these algorithms it's just not gonna
happen
so anyway let's like so like how do we
even start to address this problem it
seems like very very like huge and it is
I've spent like 10 years trying to think
about it and here's the real issue right
so we have a web application it talks to
like multiple api's those api is end up
talking to databases and their storage
solutions and like I've written
databases like a bunch of them from
quite a while now
and what a database does really is that
it takes a serialization of like your
data structure and then it stores it on
disk and it stores it on disk with a
bunch of other computers usually in a
network and it makes guarantees about
the state of that data the thing that
you you probably don't even realize as a
developer because you kind of take it
for granted is that there are state
guarantees and consistency guarantees in
that serialization to disk that bubble
all the way up to the API and the state
that comes out then and then all the
caching layers that we build on those
api is to make them fast and so if we
want to like remove this API layer that
is so problematic and figure out how to
distribute it and decentralize it and
make it part of the open web we actually
have to go with and dig all the way into
where that data gets serialized and
bring that into like into the browser
into the open web into a space that we
can actually work with so this will
become a little bit clearer as as I move
along but that's why we have to dig so
deep into this problem is because you
all of these layers in between have
consistency guarantees that bubble level
all the way from how you store data we
have to literally start to rethink what
happened when we have a data structure
in memory and we need to share it or to
serialize it long term like what happens
when it leaves the space of the memory
of our programs that's the problem we
need to solve so we come back to the
Earle like we the Earl has a central
authority in it we're gonna have all the
same problems so like to get rid of the
transport in the authority also because
we don't have an authority we don't have
like like the authority also provides a
namespace so we can't have like these
human names we go and create the things
we can do so eventually people figured
out that you can do this thing where you
hash the content and people have been
using hashes for a very long time but
every five years or so we look at
hashing and we realized that there's
like another problem that we can solve
with this and another whole scope of
issues that we can solve with it and so
our view of what we can do with
cryptographic hashing keeps getting
bigger and bigger and bigger right and
promise I'm not going to talk about
block chains so we we have this so what
we have this primitive
called content addressability or content
addressing right and the interesting
thing about content addressability is
that we get a way to address data
without an authority without a location
without a transport we can get the data
from anywhere from anybody and we have a
cryptographic guarantee that like you
told me about this hash and I got it
from like some Rando and I looked at the
data and said oh add those matches hash
it's kind of brilliant and then if that
data has inside of it other hashes then
changing any of those links inside of
that data changes the hash and so we
have another cryptographic guarantee if
the data ever changes I'm just gonna
move along and start to show some of
this in practice at this point because
either you're following along or you're
not and you're not gonna get if I keep
just talking okay so a protocol is we
created this thing called a CID or
content identifier so CID is just a very
very flexible way to say okay we have a
hash and then we need to know how to
interpret that hash to get links out of
it because we're not all gonna use the
exact same data format so that's a
little bit so you can think of it as
like sort of like a replacement for the
earth at uses cryptographic hashing okay
so if I want to like you know publish my
blog data and you want to go read it you
would say oh go get this this content
hash and then you would get back this
object that has my post event okay and
here's here's the fun thing it just
doesn't matter how you get this hash
right like I'm not gonna talk about a
bunch of peer-to-peer technologies and
dhts and ways to get it data because it
literally doesn't matter you could pull
it out of a centralized store you could
pull it out of a local storage cache
like anyway the nobody cares like it's
all you have the same cryptographic
guarantees so this is how we can create
truly decentralized data structures
without worrying about like oh well did
I authenticate with the right
peer-to-peer network and things like
that anyway inside of this data
structure I have a list of posts and
then one of those posts just points to
another cid it's just a link right we're
just creating new link data just like we
did in the internet and then when I go
and get that cid
from where
again I will then get the text for that
post fairly simple okay but now Sally
like has a list of her favorite blogs
and she's like oh yeah well Michaels
blog is this hash so boom that's in my
list I'm now publishing that data and
Heather creates an aggregator and she's
like oh cool there's this new link now
and now we're starting to build some of
the same network effects that we had in
the early web with links for data so all
of my data that I publish all my tweets
they're not just like locked up in
Twitter or locked up into Facebook or
wherever they're actually part of like a
completely decentralized system that
spans the Internet where anybody can
link to anybody's data so the really
cool thing here is like different people
can be hosting this data right it
doesn't have to live in the same place
if I'm only looking at others aggregator
and I don't really want to go look at my
blog I don't even have to resolve that
link or all of this could be on my
computer because I pulled it all down to
read all of this data offline nothing
changes in the data structures it's all
just content addressed ok so let's look
at like a more kind of real-world use
case so different universities published
in omics data different scientific data
and then people run regression analysis
over that data the way this looks today
is that they publish it in like just
random different FTP sites and tarballs
and stuff and then everybody goes and
downloads that and like different
universities trying to mirror each
other's data but they all use different
protocols and it's it's like really
really messy so if we if we imagine this
world where we have content address data
and you actually put all of that
genomics data into content dress then I
can create a regression data set that is
also a hash they just point to all the
hashes that I'm going to run against
right at all of these different places
and I can pull all of that data down in
real time from all of these universities
or mirrors of those universities or
local caches again all of the sort of
deliverability semantics are then
removed from the data structures so we
get a lot more reliability we get a lot
more permanent sand-like archive ability
which is really important and then the
really cool thing is that when I get
that result that regression result that
ran across that entire data set I can
point down at individual parts of the
data right like
same way that you would like to look
down and look at individual posts I can
look at you know this is just the part
of the genomics they did that match some
query that I had and again I can pull
down all that data and riho stit and
republish it but actually my data
structure is the only thing that I worry
about need to worry about being
published and staying alive all of these
links they go off to other places those
are in the network those exist I don't
have to Rijo s-- them I'm just adding
new value to or and also deriving value
from the data that's in the network
similarly like let's imagine like a
Twitter that's built on you centralize
data structures so Bob Alice and Sally
and Heather are all publishing their
feeds somewhere and my feed is just a
pointer to all of their feeds that's
what I'm looking at right and my
favorites is just pointing to all the
individual treats inside of their data
structures and they're hosting them or
I'm hosting them or it doesn't matter
right that's kind of the point and of
course this data structure is the exact
this looks exactly like let's slide from
a little bit ago even though these data
structures are completely different like
the way that we would want to do you
know genomics data and the way that we
would do tweets looks very different
from like you know the actual data
structures point of view but I'm able to
display it in the same way here because
all built on this same really really
tiny primitive this continent in the
fire so CID is a pointer that spans the
internet essentially you can think about
it like when you're building data
structures and you're building B trees
like if you've you know had a Google
interview and then never done that again
you you have pointers to data and it's
like a very simple programming concept
but if you think about a pointer that
can span the internet then now you can
imagine building out data structures
like B trees that span more than just
you know the memory space inside of my
hard drive and also don't just span you
know a particular data silo for a
particular website as quote as me I said
that I'm smart so so but at the end of
the day what we end up with is a network
of data this hugely giant valuable
network of data write effectively like
an Internet of data just built on this
simple primitive right now if you start
to imagine all this
data out there existing all these people
building value on top of it you stop
trying to compare this to a particular
Amazon offering or this to Facebook or
this to Twitter right
those are huge applications it's hard to
imagine anybody ever competing with them
but just like my AOL blog was not
competing or sorry my Oprah blog is not
competing with Oprah's content the whole
network was competing with that content
in the same way if we're creating this
internet a data and deriving all this
value those old applications that are
locked up in data silos are actually
competing with the entire value of the
network that means that we can actually
win we can actually like move all of
this data and start moving our next
application basis all into this new
model where we're not locked up in all
these companies and all these data silos
anymore so that's the vision that we
have that we're trying to build I'm
working on that a protocol labs a lot of
people are working on this a lot of
people are working looking at content or
s ability where it's like the earliest
days ever like we are still implementing
fundamental data structures we're doing
a lot of new research and new work if
you're really interested in this I would
like really encourage you to go check
out this spec repository this is
probably like the best list of grammar
and current work that we have like in
like a more human readable format and
we're of course working on like a lot of
new content and then on top of these
data structures we built things like
IGFs the interplanetary file system
which can move your files around and all
of that I peeled d stands for
interplanetary linked data yeah because
we we love acronyms that immediately
make the intergalactic song by Beastie
Boys playing my head so but anyway that
that is my talk I finished up a little
bit early very nice I always talk faster
than I wanted to so thank you so much
and please join us on making the next
version of the web
[Applause]